[Musique]
comme la propagation du virus la
multiplication de vidéos mensongère et
trompeuse se poursuit une vidéo en
particulier mais on a l'embarras du
choix mais en voici un autre bon exemple
et comme vous allez le voir tout au long
de cette vidéo
toutes ces personnalités reconnues
mondialement affirmant même chose les
chiffres que les médias nous donne sont
fous coronavirus les chiffres sont faux
c'est le titre de cette vidéo visionnée
au moment d'enregistrer cette capsule à
près de 800 mille reprises
en gros tout au long de ce monologue de
17 minutes
le narrateur évoque une série assez
impressionnante d'affirmations qui
minimise l'importance de la pandémie de
coved 19
au menu informations fausses détourné
inexactes ou prise hors contexte
parmi les affirmations qui pose problème
le corps n'a virus n'est pas dangereux
puisqu'il est peu mortelle et ne tue que
les personnes âgées et les gens déjà
malade
d'abord même s'il est vrai que le taux
de mortalité de lakovic 19 est
relativement bas en général le grand
danger de lakovic 19 et celui qu'il pose
pour notre système de santé en entier la
grande inquiétude en ce moment c'est que
la pandémie surcharge des hôpitaux
ce qui met en danger non seulement les
personnes atteintes de lakovic 19 mais
aussi toutes les autres personnes qui
nécessite aussi des soins médicaux
une autre affirmation fausse et véhiculé
dans cette vidéo la pandémie et
l'engorgement des hôpitaux qui en
découlent sont identiques à ceux qui
s'observent pendant la grippe
saisonnière
faux contrairement à la grippe
la coved 19 génère un nombre
inhabituellement élevé de patients qui
nécessitent une hospitalisation de
longue durée pour l'urgentologue et
président de l'association des
spécialistes en médecine d'urgence du
québec
la différence entre la kobe 19 et la
grippe saisonnière c'est que l'aco b19
cause d'un syndrome respiratoire grave
dans bien des cas qui nécessitent
beaucoup de spécialisation et le recours
beaucoup plus fréquent au soutien
respiratoires en terminant cette vidéo
emploi une méthode classique de mes
informations sortir des affirmations
d'experts de leur contexte et surtout
amputer ses affirmations des portions
qui nuisent aux énoncés que le narrateur
tente de faire passer comme étant
politiques
l'article de jefferies dessus sur cette
vidéo est vraiment
à lire ce n'était ainsi que la pointe de
l'iceberg l'équipe des décrypteurs
attend d'ailleurs vos questions écrivez
nous et n'oubliez pas de nous joindre
via notre groupe facebook
salut
[Musique]